right and thank you so much for joining
us today it's an honor to speak with you
and I know I speak for many here in the
audience when I say that we've been
looking forward to this for quite some
time
Thank You Gerald's I wanted to start at
the beginning of your career as the Dean
mentioned you were educated at Cornell's
and architect in a structural engineer
and plan to spend the rest of your
career in the United States but you
returned to India
starting on the shop floor and I wonder
what that was like as a young man
returning from the United States to
India well quite frankly it was as much
a cultural shock I'd been away for 10
years and things had changed and yet
they had not changed and the difference
was quite substantive in addition to
which I didn't return to India to spend
time on the shop floor so I didn't
really understand what was being done
and several times during that period of
time I thought of going back to the US
and pursuing my career as an architect
and you spent several years as a Dean
mentioned moving around different parts
of the Tata organization were you
surprised when you got the call from
your uncle in 1991 to be chairman of
Tata yes I was mainly because there were
many contenders were not many can know
the handful of contenders for that
position from his own team of people and
it happened very suddenly and and you
you begin to feel that a leader he was
there for 50-plus years as chairman and
you start to believe that somebody's
immortal in that he's going to be there
perpetually so when he calls you and
says this is what he wants to do
it shakes you up and suddenly you feel
all alone right and you Fester quite a
formidable challenge as the azzedine
mentioned when you took over CEO the
organization Tata was large and
sprawling with independent business
heads that regarded they owned their own
businesses their own personal fiefdom
didn't necessarily play together well
and you were in an economy that was
changing rapidly and your uncle was
considered a Titan of Indian business
and very large shoes for a young CEO to
fill how did you go about establishing
your credibility as a leader in those
early days I had two problems one was
with the actual market problems of a
large business house that had operated
very traditionally and and the other was
internal to the company of several
titans if you might who who didn't want
any change to take place and I guess a
certain amount of resentment also so the
first five years were akin to a Clint
Eastwood if you might which which tended
to be filled with trying to get these
elderly very prominent people out out of
the way who have not done with bullets
it was done with persuasion and and I'm
sorry to say with money so the first
five years were spent in creating an
environment with change was possible and
then I've been blessed with an
organization that has been displaying
considerable spirit in wanting to make a
change and many things that we did had
not been done before but I was always
pleased to see that the response from
the organization was tremendous without
that it could not have been done and one
of the things that many of our Sierra
students we study is the
show of organizations in the face of
change how did you go to inspire the
leaders and frontline staff to to
believe in the vision that you set out
and some of the changes that you wish to
implement that was difficult and to some
extent I would have to humbly say that I
failed one one of the first promises I
made publicly was that we'd rationalize
the group and reduce the number of
businesses and reduce the number of
companies I often talk about the first
thing that I did with great gusto which
was to get us out of the soaps and
toiletry business which didn't seem to
fit and I ran a headlong into an issue
of what were we doing we were getting
rid of a company that at second and
third generation employees it was an
unheard-of thing and who was this person
who was making change for the sake of
change right and I got attacked from all
quarters the media attack made that the
stock market attacked me and of course
there was a resentment from within
within the company so which company
would follow now after this that result
was a new Chairman so keen to succeed
and not wishing to have failure suddenly
being bombarded from old quarters there
was no second company that got good soul
right and I put my tail between my legs
and and tried to look at other forms of
of growing right and you've said in the
past that risk is a necessary part of a
business philosophy and certainly over
your career you've made some significant
bets and the Dean mentioned a number of
the acquisitions I would also think here
of the launch of the indica Indian's
first indigenously manufactured motor
vehicle how did you get comfortable
making such consequential decisions and
to your point convey
saying others to follow you into them I
think convincing myself that it would
work was is it is a judgment called in
terms of the faith you put in your
people to do this in case in pointers on
the indica conventional wisdom said that
you couldn't enter the car business
without having a collaboration and
certainly to think of designing a car
domestically and producing it was an
unheard of thinking my friends as we
launched the car started to distance
themselves for me and it wasn't for me
it was to distance themselves from
failure right and it was the trust one
had in the young young team to put this
together that drove it the the other is
that from time to time I think change
has caused a lot of people in the
company to to question the wisdom that
such a change would would be based on
and I've been lucky and in some cases
it's been difficult but by and large in
his country that has such a great
potential that changes by and large well
received right and we've heard a lot of
anxiety about the Indian economy and we
know that there's a lot of potential
there but there's been recently at least
a lot of noise in the press about how
reform hasn't kept pace with growth and
it's possibly cramping India's growth
potential what do you think lies ahead
for the future of India well you know i
I've always been very positive about the
new India and I've been saddened by the
fact that after several years of very
progressive growth there's been a
stumbling activity that it has been a
country driven by accusations of
corruption
not wrong icky rightly so
crony capitalism and a government that
has we drawn its pace of of growth right
at the same time I feel that that has
been that is bottom doubt and we're on a
path again to grow but we've got to
rebuild we've gone from an eight eight
percent plus growth rate down to sub
five briefly right we will grow back to
the growth rate we had we will need to
control inflation but I think India will
once again the same spirit of the people
will make it make it happen right and
one of the things that you mentioned is
that's often remarked about India and
for that matter a number of emerging
markets is this phenomenon of crony
capitalism and you've spoken in the past
about how you value personal integrity
both in your own leadership but in also
in the leaders you admire have you ever
faced an opportunity which you had to
turn down for for ethical reasons or for
the ethical consequences of that
decision so several several instances
with where that would be so that I think
perhaps the the most visible one was
when we wanted to form an airline oddly
enough we were asked to form an airline
by by the then Prime Minister
but vested interests made made sure that
we didn't form an airline through three
successive Prime Minister's and that was
the most visible of of the thing which
we walked away from because we could
have probably had it by succumbing to
subjective issues of bribery or
corruption and we walked away from it
with airline would have been something
we really wanted to do we pioneered
aviation in in the turn of the century
right and it was
emotionally something that we would have
liked very much to be in again right and
I bet you and and your uncle jRD were
both aviation enthusiasts yes we I can
imagine the disappointment that master
you must have felt one of the one of the
hallmarks of your your ten-year CEO has
in fact been the move away from from
India and transforming Tata from an
Indian business into a true
multinational what prompted the move
abroad and and what were some of the
biggest challenges you faced in doing so
to a great extent it was the the issue
of having the need to grow and I need to
take of you that you'd grown in India in
some cases we had a fairly substantial
market share and that as a group we
ought to look beyond the shores of India
to another economic cycle in which we
would operate now that has its pluses
and minuses we didn't ever foresee that
Europe would go through the downturn it
it did and that was where our major
investments lay so it was a quest for
growth and and changing the ground rules
to say that we could grow by
acquisitions which earlier we had never
done right the international expansion
there was not without some controversy
and aside from the economic rationale
there was also emotional consequences
and I'm thinking here of the acquisition
of Tetley tea and the idea of a beloved
British tea brand being bought by an
Indian company must have stood some
hearts in England and yes if they did it
was quite quiet and dignified the more
vocal one would and the more vocal bond
was when Jaguar and Land Rover got
acquired right and that was far more
emotional and far more visible
different different reactions from
different quarters some in some concern
that an Indian company was going to take
over vaulted to very venerable brands
and what were they going to do with it
Ford had made and not been able to make
a profit with them so what was this
Indian company that had no experience in
the premium car segment do with such a
company concerned by the workers that we
were going to close down plants and move
them to India and a general feeling that
in England that another British brand
was gone
quite frankly all we did after we got
involved was to tell the management of
the company to make their own destiny
that we'd support them in terms of what
they wanted to do and of course the
marketplace has been very conducive to
what we have done right so I think the
Jaguar Land Rover thing was much more
fiery than a tea and then there's got
very very quietly and as I said and very
dignified way no doubt the British stuff
Apple it was whatever you are there one
of the remarkable aspects of Tata is its
sheer complexity it strikes me as being
an enormous ly difficult challenge to be
able to manage this company day-to-day
you have as a Dean mentioned almost half
a million employees worldwide over 100
operating companies 36 of which are
publicly listed Dominic Barton of
McKinsey when he was here this week
spoke about great leaders needing to
have both a microscope and a telescope
that is an ability to focus on the fine
details where they really count but also
to see the larger picture and see the
secular trends transforming their
markets how did you go about managing
Tata a day-to-day and balance that need
for a micro and a macro perspective I
think by and large all our companies
have had strong CEOs that have run the
business
and the only only thing I would say is
that I've had a funny type of role where
you you sit apart looking at the overall
company on a strategic basis and then
when there's a problem you go into the
company much more than may happen answer
in the world where you find yourself
playing the same role as a CEO in terms
of either firefighting or or moving a
company in another direction and then
move back again into a macro position
where you're looking at the company or
the group in its broader sense okay so
it exactly what you said is
inadvertently has been what wood has
been done and how did you make sure that
you had the information you needed to
make the decisions so we've had past
pftt CEOs come in and speak about how
they would covertly conduct visits to
the frontline and visit factory floors
just to get to to gauge the spirit
morale they workforce I think that
that's an absolute given the worst thing
that can happen is do is to determine
where the company is going through the
eyes or or the mouth of one person I
give the CEO right farmer is gained by
walking on the shop floor and talking to
the people and trying to communicate one
of my weaknesses has been a I think I've
never communicated and now for
adequately with our people partly
because I'm a shy person and secondly
because I didn't realize the importance
of communication but I think
communication with the employees is an
exceedingly important function that any
company chairman has to do and be
visible in that sense did you ever have
to overrule or disagree with decisions
made by some of the leaders of your
businesses based on information you are
hearing from the frontline yes very much
so
and that that's usually quite an
eye-opener because
you have a trusted CEO and you find
either inadvertently or consciously
you're getting a colored picture of a
situation another one of the approaches
that you took it at Tata which is a
hallmark of your tenure is the focus on
the bottom of the pyramid consumer and
we all know the story of the Tata Nano
and a number of us visited your factory
last year in Gujarat and I was
pleasantly surprised to find that I
could fit quite comfortably inside glad
you did
well I hid it was modeled after after
you so that someone of your stature
needed to fit comfortably but the the
Nano as we spoke about before the
interview has also met with some some
challenges and so I'm curious whether
you're still as enthusiastic about the
bottom of the pyramid market today and
what lessons you take from the the Nano
episode a good good question you think
in the Indian market the known consumer
markets about 250 to 300 million people
if you take the base of the pyramid and
look at at developing products below
that and into the into the segments of
the market that's moving into that
consuming era area the market sizes
extends to 500 to 600 million people
that's a huge market 300 to which you
don't have products to address so if you
can think of how to how to reach that
down to reach that market you have an
exceedingly large potential market in a
case in point might be the cell phone
industry in India when I grew up in in
school you waited seven to ten years to
get a telephone there was a
a government incumbent company or
government monopoly that had limitations
to refuse to grow rates were high so
apart from people like me a little
shopkeeper or or a a handcart puller
let's say could never dream of having
connectivity other than through a
payphone today who would sell phones its
bypassed all of that and and the
handcart pusher can buy a prepaid SIM
card and a low-cost phone and he's
connected he has a number he can be
reached he has an identity and it's self
esteem so you have cellphone subscribers
that are maybe 600 million in India and
the fastest growing industry that the
country has seen so it has come because
technology has made a phone available
and no longer dependent on copper wires
or optical fiber and and this has
happened again who would have thought 10
years ago that you would have 500
million telephone script scribers in
India so I think the potential of the
Indian market is huge if you address
yourself to to that I don't think the
Nano adequately did that and we the
lesson we learnt is you can't do
something on the basis of trying to sell
it the same way as you would sell
another car we should have been selling
it like once sold a scooter or a
motorcycle and instead of two wheels
give them four wheels in a safe form of
family transport so we've learned our
lessons on that and
we will rectify that as as we go forward
right so important profit motives but
also social consequences of really
addressing that market yes and Tata is a
remarkable record of its involvement
with philanthropic causes and how do you
view the role of organizations like Tata
and the in particular the role of
corporate social responsibility in
addressing needs in society well I think
there's this transcends to personal life
also you've got a country with
tremendous disparity of income you've
got very rich people on the one hand and
abject poverty and the other you have to
be sensitive to the fact that this gap
cannot continue to widen while there's a
large discontented number of people who
are looking at the inequities of the
environment as they see it too for
companies therefore I think there has to
be is sensitivity to doing something in
the in the communities around which you
operate and in making an effort to to
raise the quality of life so that
there's there's not envy and distaste
for what was there but look the
companies looked at in a more positive
sense and in enhancing the quality of
life of the people around them we expend
about four percent of our net net profit
in these rural development activities
and we do it ourselves
and someone may argue that this is
shareholders money which it is but I
think it is bought
a sense of of not just tolerance but a
sense of welcoming our companies in
wherever they've been and enhancing
whatever we've been trying to do in the
product area or the services area to a
community area being part of the
community would you view the role of
corporate social responsibility it's
being quite different in the United
States versus a emerging market like
India I don't know enough about the
United States to make a comment but I
think in one form or another it becomes
an issue that all corporations will have
to have to deal with and and we I think
as as businessmen have to concern
ourselves and removing the image of
being the ugly businessman the venal
businessman and being heads of companies
or leaders whose interests go beyond
that of their company to the communities
they serve and if I think if we can do
that we can undo an image that has been
created over the last century agreed and
and self-serving desires so I think it's
something that we need to be sensitive
about Stanford has a reputation for
entrepreneurship and many of the
students here in the crowd have
aspirations to be entrepreneurs do you
think the innovation taking place in
emerging markets is going to be driven
more by multinationals like Tata or do
individual entrepreneurs have the
ability to disrupt major markets in in
India and others like it I would hope
that it's the latter I would hope that
we can home grow enterprises in in
various countries I think what the
United States has had which is very
different is its added
and environment were a good idea driven
by people who are married has a better
chance of being supported and financed
and and nurtured then you might find in
in developed countries very often a good
idea dies in in the developed country or
even I'm in a developing country or even
a developed country outside the United
States and and that person finally moves
the United States and makes a success it
is because the environment allows that
to happen so I think there's a need for
in environm environmentally but I would
hope that we would see more and more
local companies being interpreted and
creative and and being at some stage
your global player right and certainly
we've seen a number of countries try to
replicate the success of Silicon Valley
and have found that it takes a unique
mix of ingredients you know whether it's
human capital legal institutions and so
on are you hopeful that India will be
able to to create that dynamic within
its own country I think the potential
exists there whether India del Sur
doesn't will depend unfortunately as
your much greater extent on government
policy than it does in a totally free
environment I mentioned when he took
over that many many external observers
they thought you had large shoes to fill
on taking over from your uncle now with
another transition of power Cyrus
Pallonji Mistry has his own large shoes
to fill that of yourself I wonder what
advice you would give Cyrus as he takes
takes on his task as chairman I've told
Cyrus that he needs to be his own person
that finally was something I did now I
realized the shoes that I had to fill
were far too big for me to mimic the
person ever I was following
and I just decided to just be myself and
do what I thought was right would be the
way to go
I've told Cyrus the same thing I think
he he should feel that he is being his
own person and let his personality and
his conscience if you might drive him
right in a moment I'm going to turn it
over to the audience for four questions
that one last question before we do here
in Stanford we ask one question of all
our applicants of the MBA program which
is what matters most to you and why I
wonder how you'd answer that question
I'd obviously fail in Stanford because I
don't know how I can answer that
question I to me I think short-term the
transition of suddenly having a lot of
time and being able to be the master at
that time is the lovely luxury whether
that luxury becomes boredom as time goes
on is something that will need to be
seen and how it gets filled with other
pursuits as head of the trust I I will
be involved in some of the things we've
talked about in the in the past few
minutes of trying to make a difference
in what and the quality of life of the
people in in India but to what extent it
my next few years will lead lead me to
fulfill that or change from that view I
don't know so with humility I'd have to
say I wouldn't fall into the success
mode that the Stanford Graduate would in
answering your question well I think of
a lifetime of service that we can we can
draw our own conclusions to some of the
things that have clearly mattered to you
in terms of the impact that you've had
on India I think I think if seriously if
if I said I would like to be
seen as being someone who could continue
to try to make a difference I think that
would be a very satisfying thing for me
to achieve I think that's a great point
too to turn it over to questions a
question we have been struggling with in
some of our classes is the role that
large companies have in creating macro
change and you're clearly doing that in
India and wondering if you have any
anecdotes of ways in which you've been
able by your position to influence the
government to make certain decisions
that were in the best interest of the
country when maybe they wouldn't have
your your question relates to how weird
how weird channeling deciding how how
and where to channel our funds in in
that sense or almost the the influence
that large business large business that
is that has a vision for it for good for
the country can have in changing or
influencing policy pot I'm positively
okay I think I don't know if I'm
answering your question adequately but I
think large business has has to have an
element of of orienting themselves to to
serve a social need also in addition to
just serving a a business need and in
our case I think there's we we may be
driven by by a business motivation but
we we should always be conscious of of
areas that we feel are not in the public
interest and now going into dangerous
waters but we would draw from
activities in the in the liquor business
because we felt that this was an area
that that tended to be serving a
consumer base that we that perhaps we
didn't want to be in we look very hard
about being in in certain natural
resource business which which had become
rather venal in terms of how those
businesses were run and I think
similarly we've entered businesses may
be small in a small way which have been
what we considered to be a worthwhile
thing to do for the communities that
we've been in but I don't think there's
there's been in in open na in a very
constructive way to do what you've which
you've suggested as here
you